初めてのフットサルどうでしたいや楽しい
ですねやっぱりクラブに加入しますかはい
します
月いくらでしたっけ
4989円になります今
払ってもいいですかもちろん大丈夫です
LINEPay使えますかねごめんなさい
現金のみになりますですよねじゃあえっと
5000円からすみませんが定額をこの
封筒の中に入れていただけますか次回で
大丈夫ですのでもしよかったらこの
5000円札を受け取ってくださいでその
定額以上に受け取るなんてできませんよ
あーはいそれはわかりますでも必要な
コインを集めるのにもっとお金がかかり
ますはいATMで引き出したら200円
かかりますし
窓口でやろうと思えば多分15分ぐらい
待たなければなりませんのでコンビニで
崩すといいですよそしたらお金がかかり
ませんしかしコンビニは物が高いからお金
はかかりますはいしかもたくさんのものを
3回ぐらい分けて買わない限り必要な
コインが揃いませんコンビニの値段が心配
ならスーパーで崩せばいいですよ食材は
全部ネットで買ってますすいません
余っている11円もう寄付しますのでいや
お客様に負担をかけるなんてできません
いやですから
ちなみにジャージーダイが別になります
このもう一つの封筒に入れてくださいはい
3979円になりますコンビニの人に変態
だと思われるなこれ何かおっしゃいました
かいや何でもないですお支払いはできそう
ですかはい次回持ってきますよろしくお
願いします
あでもこれならコインがあんまり戻ってこ
ないなこれならコインが戻ってくるけど
ネットで買った方がよっぽど安いなこれ
ならもういいや
お箸は要りますかいやいらないですはい
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ます
めんどくさいし
しまったLINEPayで払っちゃった